I want to introduce you to my badass
friends meet Thelma and Louise I'm
passionate about cows and although
they've been getting into a lot of crap
lately due to methane emissions and
climate change I hope that I can redeem
their reputation in part by showing you
how incredibly important they are in
solving one of the world's biggest
problems
food security but more importantly for
Africa its resultant childhood stunting
stunting nutritional stunting manifests
itself in a reduction of growth rate in
human development and according to
UNICEF stunting doesn't come easy it
doesn't come quickly it happens over a
long period of time during which a child
enjoys painful and debilitating cycles
of illness depressed appetite
insufficient nutrition and inadequate
care and most kids simply can't endure
such rudeness but those that do survive
they carry forward long term cognitive
problems as well as losses of stature
the numbers of stunted children under
the under the age of five in most
regions of the world has been declining
and I really hate to say this but the
only place where they haven't been
defining is here in Africa here 59
million children 3 and 10 in that age
group struggle to meet their genetic
potential their full genetic potential
protein is one of our most important
dietary requirements and evidence shows
that lack of essential amino acids are
building blocks of proteins in young
children's diets can result in stunting
essential amino acids are called
essential because we can't synthesize
them in our bodies we have to get them
from our foods and the best sources are
animal derived milk meat and eggs most
protein consumed on the African
continent
is crop based and although we have
millions of smallholder farmers rearing
animals and livestock production is not
as easy as we think
the big livestock gaps between rich
countries and poor countries a due to
poor animal health endemic livestock
diseases some of them transmissible to
humans threaten not only livestock
producers in those poor countries but
all human health across all countries
this is a global pathogens Network
it shows the pathogens found across the
world according to the enhanced
infectious diseases database and it
shows those pathogens that share hosts
in a nutshell we share pathogens and
thus diseases with the species we live
closest to our livestock and we call
these zoonotic diseases recent reports
show that the deadly dozen zoonotic
diseases kill 2.2 million people and
sickened 2.4 billion people annually and
Jimmy says the greatest burden of
zoonosis falls on 1 billion poor
livestock keepers we totally
underestimate the importance of our
small holder farmers we're beginning to
recognize how important they are and how
they influence our medical health our
biosafety and more recently our
cognitive and our physical health they
stand at the front line of zoonotic
epidemics they pretty much underpin our
existence and they need to know so much
yet most lack knowledge on livestock
disease prevention and treatment so how
do they learn apart from shared
experiences trial and error conventional
farming extension services our boots on
the ground and radio expensive and hard
to scale in the face of population
growth
sounds pretty gloomy doesn't it but
we're at an interesting point in Africa
we're changing that narrative using
innovative solutions riding across
scalable technologies knowledge doesn't
have to be expensive
my company developed a agricultural
platform called AI cow
we teach farmers best livestock
practices using SMS over simple low-end
phones farmers receive three SMS is a
week on best livestock practices and
those that execute the messages go on to
see increases in productivity within a
shorter time as three months and those
the first increases in productivity of
course are improved animal health we use
SMS because it is retentive farmers
store their messages they write them
down in books and in effect we're
drip-feeding agricultural manuals into
the field we recognize that we are all
part of the global food network
producers and consumers you and me and
every farmer and oft we're focusing now
on trying to bring together producers
and consumers to take action and become
take responsibility for not only food
security but for food safety this
beautiful animal is an African Asian
zywall crossed with a Dutch flick V
she's milkier than has iowa mum and she
sturdier and more resistant to disease
than her flick v father in ethiopia and
tanzania the african dairy genetic gains
program is using SMS and cutting-edge
genomics in pioneering Africa's first
tropically adapted dairy breeding
centers and dairy performance recording
centres farmers contribute their data
their production data
milking records breeding records and
feeding records to the ad DG platform
this data is synthesized through
algorithms from some of the top
livestock institutions in the world
before it lands back in the farmers
hands in actionable sms's customized
data customized responses all aimed at
increasing productivity based on the
potential on the ground we're in a very
interesting place in agriculture in
Africa by the end of this year we'll
have almost 1 billion mobile phone
subscriptions we have the power in our
hands to ensure that livestock
production
systems are not only healthy productive
and profitable but that farmers are
knowledgeable but more importantly that
our farmers are safe working with
smallholder farmers is one of the best
ways to guarantee food security working
with smallholder farmers is one of the
best ways to guarantee each and every
child their full opportunity and ability
to reach their full genetic potential
and harnessing the power of millions of
smallholder farmers and their badass
cows like mine we should be able to
bring a halt to stunting in Africa
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]